so the next the next session is uh
looking at expertise and knowledge and
innovation from the educational
establishments in suffolk and norfolk
and uh hearing what they're doing we've
got three
three sessions
uh running to find out what's happening
in those
particular establishments and it's so
important isn't it this is young people
this is
their future their work since since we
kicked off greenless county i keep going
back in time as you would i've now got
two two i didn't have two children when
i was kicked off greenless county so
i've now got two at 10 and 13. and boy
do they focus your mind on what they're
going to inherit from me in 10 20 30 40
years time it really does make you you
focus on on what young people want and
what they deserve so without further ado
i think with first of all we've got west
suffolk college
dora martinez carbonell and she is
recorded
hello everyone my name is dora martinez
and i am the sustainability initiatives
lead um at the sustainability center at
west suffolk college so i'm going to
tell you a bit more about uh what we do
at the sustainability center
and also how you can get involved as
well
[Music]
but first i would like just to show
these um these this figure this is the
2021 global race outlook by the world
economic forum
so basically what this shows is um
how the global businesses perceive
global risks that can actually affect uh
their businesses
so as we can see in the top right corner
we're seeing their climate action
failure we see environmental human
environmental damage extreme weather
events biodiversity laws
so it's been for a few years now over
the last four or five years that
decline the climate crisis is actually
perceived as the number one risk for
businesses
so it's clear that we have to to start
doing things differently because
otherwise we are at risk that our
businesses will collapse
and also i'm sure that these will be
will have been discussed um during this
event
uh we have to think about um
[Music]
the the legally binding commitment to
net zero by 2050 i mean all
organizations no matter what size no
matter what revenue no matter what
sector all organizations must comply
with that
um here in the uk so we really need
action we really need change
so
yeah for the first time in history we
understand the drivers of the climate
crisis we understand how we got here but
not only that we also are starting to
suffer the effects of the climate crisis
so it is urgent that we change things
but the good news is that we have the
knowledge technology and means to start
changing things and to start doing
businesses
business in a very different
way
so
in this figure in here what we see are
the different um
is the value chain of any given
organization so we see how the different
uh
the different
operations um the different areas of any
given organization let's say or
different departments
actually work in collaboration both
internally and externally we cannot
think that we will solve this uh working
in isolation we need to work in
collaboration with all our stakeholders
both inside of our organizations and
also those externals which are
our suppliers our contractors and also
um our customers and clients and
ultimately the wider society
so as i'm saying here there is so little
we can directly control
because again we don't work in isolation
but there is so much that we can that we
can influence
how we do that or how should we do that
where is the opportunity in here well i
like to talk about these uh less acronym
like leadership engagement synergies and
collaboration
so we must take the lead so others can
follow
then we need to engage again not only uh
with our external um
with our external stakeholders but also
with our internal extend stakeholder
that's our staff members our employees
and then we have to look for those
synergies through collaboration both in
and out again in and out of our um of
our scope of action
so
that's exactly what we do at the
sustainability center our west afro
college
so we
work both internally and externally so
we work internally with
students as well as with lecturers and
and all the staff members across
different departments
and also we support local organizations
to transition to sustainable practices
so
how do we do that well i am the let's
say the internal face of the
sustainability center so i work
with two tours with lecturers with head
of departments um with people across
different departments not only teaching
departments but also
procurement
hatar etc
so i work with everyone and also with
the students to see how sustainability
can be embedded into everything that we
do so with teachers i work to see how
they can
embed sustainability and bring
sustainability into the curriculum
i also deliver um
workshops for the students just for them
to feel empowered and to take the lead
and see how they can actually
implement sustainability when moving
forward in their careers actually
so uh we are setting up a student
society a green student society that we
will be launching
in early november
and then we are also putting um the
sustainability awards together and you
will have you will find more information
in our website but we want to bring
together students businesses and and all
the staff members um in our in our
community in west afro college
so we will be hosting a sustainability
award ceremony in june um 2022 and
hopefully uh we will see you there as
well
so um yeah so basically it's all about
driving action and taking plenties and
and and com
i mean um
[Music]
taking also commitment but we don't also
we don't only want to be just words we
want action
and then my colleague chloe we we will
talk about her um in the following slide
so she basically focus her action
externally sees the external face of the
sustainability center so she works in
the sustainability center business
program and she brings
organizations together she's creating a
network of local businesses interested
in bringing sustainability into their
operations
so she creates free tools and resources
and also the network of course is a
space for exchanging experiences and see
what it works and what it doesn't work
see how the different businesses across
east anglia can collaborate uh and join
forces
and then of course we have also the
fully funded iuma courses
ayima is the um the institute for
environmental management and assessment
so we offer courses for the workforce
for managers and also for leadership
groups
uh so i think that this is the most
interesting part for the audience here
today so i just wanted to expand a bit
more um about the uh the business side
of the sustainability center
so again chloe is your go-to person um
with anything to do with the
sustainability center business program
so if you want to join the network
please drop hairline you also will find
more information about what we do in our
website
um
and then regarding the ajima courses i
do deliver a couple of them and then
another colleague delivers uh the third
one so as we're seeing here uh we have
skills for the workforce environmental
sustainability skills for managers and
then the foundation certificate in
environmental management
so the skills for the workforce are
basically focused in um climate science
and all the very basics of
sustainability
um drivers and consequences of the
climate
emergency and also we see a bit of
carbon accountancy environmental
management systems such as iso 14001
so it's basically for staff members in
your organization who want to um
to start bringing sustainability into
the roads
then the one for managers is for uh team
leaders and for managers who want to
drive action within their teams
so it's very much um
it is very much
the first day because this one runs for
two days so the first day is very much
focused in the same like like the
workforce but then in the second day we
will talk about um
about communication tools how you can
actually bring people on board how you
can actually uh negotiate with people um
we will also talk about data reporting
um so yeah we will give you tools for
you to move forward with the
sustainability agenda and and create um
create a network of sustainability
champions
so the first course
runs for one full day we have here the
next following days we have the first
one is the 15th of november you can you
will have the option to attend online or
in person i always recommend in person
of course and then the other one the
skills for managers runs for two days
so we have spread that into two weeks so
the first
yeah we will do debates that you have in
here so the first course will run on the
17th and the 24th of november and then
january and then march
and then the last one the environmental
management foundation certificate it is
taught by my colleague richard carter
he is a non-executive director ataima
and he has a wealth of experience in
sustainability he used to be
finance and sustainability manager at um
at the brewery um adams so he he's he's
great
and this course is um is quite intense
and intensive it is for five days five
full days um the course will run in five
consecutive weeks as opposed to five
consecutive days
um so in this course this course is very
much recommended for the executive team
leaders in the organizations for them to
better understand how to embed
sustainability throughout all the
operations and business strategies
so there you have them like the three
courses um i would like to stress that
if you want to join the sustainability
network
uh the bus in the business program with
my colleague chloe
those courses will be fully funded for
all the employees that you want to
sign up for the courses but if you want
to just do the courses and not join the
network then you will need to um
to bear the cost of of the course
but i mean we are fully funded by the
european union yes still so um anything
and everything that we do is for free so
all the support that you get all the
resources the tools the courses the ima
courses everything is free um and open
to all the sms in east anglia so please
join us
at the sustainability center
and then just to finish i would like to
um to use this uh this bold statement by
philly giubert um philip is the founder
and director at earth on board
that's um it is a company
which helps
big corporations to adopt sustainability
into the business practices and
operations and strategies
uh so he always opens his meetings with
this bold statement business as usual is
dead i mean indeed
it's been proved that the systems in
place don't work uh don't work for the
people and certainly don't work for the
planet so we know that we must change
the way we do things the way we do the
way we live and the way we do business
in the planet
uh so the good names as i say at the
beginning of the presentation today is
that we know how to do it we have the
tools we have the knowledge
and the sustainability center can
support you doing uh so can support you
in your journey to sustainability
so please join us uh please drop me a
line you have here my email address my
contact details um also please go on to
our website
and explore all the different things
that we do
and i do hope to um hear from you in the
coming weeks and hopefully we will work
together okay so thank you very much and
um yeah i hope to see you soon thank you
thank you dora west suffolk college
uh so and without further ado can i
introduce
rachel
and kerry from
east coast college
there you go
so um thank you for um inviting us along
this afternoon my name is kerry payne
i'm the assistant principal at east
coast college for higher education in
particular
this is my colleague rachel bunn so
rachel bunn is our assistant principal
for quite a few complex areas within the
college so that involves apprenticeships
employer training commercial work and
lots and lots of bits and bobs i'm sure
rachel will talk to you about
so um our college at east coast runs
numerous curriculum areas but we thought
we'd talk to you today of course about
areas that link to sustainability in
particular so we're very very lucky to
have an energy skills center at our
lowest off campus
so we've had the energy skills centre
for a few years now and we had over 11.4
million pounds investment in that centre
to train
young people and adults
as well as employers within engineering
and the energy sector curriculum in
particular
so this was funded through the new
anglian local enterprise partnership and
also jointly funded by the college
so this center if you ever had a chance
to come and visit us please do or check
it out on our website but it has
world-class state-of-the-art facilities
designed around engineering and energy
but also offshore sector and and
maritime international maritime training
as well
so to set up the center and to set up
any of the curriculum that we deliver we
do work really really closely with our
employers and local organizations
concerned with economic development and
future skills development so our
curriculum will be backed by employers
and that's particularly important for
areas in my curriculum with higher
education every single degree has to
have at least one or two employers that
actually sign their name to that
curriculum saying it will actually give
the learners the skills needed to to be
successful within that sector
um and the center curriculum has um some
constantly changing um training sorry
just missing that last point there so
such as um something exciting which
rachel will know more about but the
hybrid car charging and also
decarbonation
upskilling as well
okay so we are trying to support local
and national skills needs so we do have
training pathways all the way through
from level one starting at the base
right the way through to higher
education programs and apprenticeships
that take us through to level seven so
that is postgraduate level level
training so we do welcome existing
customers and work with the customers to
provide training for for for what they
want what they're requesting us to do
but we're also very interested in
working with new customers um as well
just to support that and further develop
the curriculum
there is an innovation
center within the energy skills center
and that works to have partnerships with
employers to deliver tailored and
bespoke courses um
just to try and help us and the employer
stay ahead of head of the curve if you
like so we're we're doing everything
that's coming through that's new
um
the energy skills center will from next
september also be one of the buildings
on our campuses that will support us
within our institute of technology so
we're working with our partners you'll
hear from shortly the university of
suffolk to develop the new anglian
institute of technology now that
institute will deliver level four plus
training so level four all the way
through to level seven particularly
within the stem subject areas so we have
a number of courses for example
conservation science
energy and the environment sustainable
futures so there's some of our degree
course titles that will be on offer for
our students um if they're particularly
interested in progressing into relevant
pathways that lead into sustainable work
thank you thank you kerry
okay good afternoon everybody so as
kerry described i've got a job title of
a multitude of sins
which includes commercial development
but also employer engagement and
apprenticeships
so as you can see on the next slide we
offer a breadth of training for industry
but as a college we can't do that alone
so it's really important for
collaboration and for partnerships now
within the energy center we've got
partnerships for example with maersk
around training the offshore wind
technicians
as a college we couldn't do that alone
but as a partnership we've actually got
an amazing training facility and a
training offer within region
so we offer pre-employment programs as
well so
for example in offshore wind we do a
transition and a foundation course
so we've had people transitioning from
offshore
um oil and gas being trained and are now
qualified wind technicians across the
world
but it's also really important around
the adult training and adult reskilling
so we work with dwp around foundation
programs and supporting career
aspirations for adults as well
we also look at licensed practices work
based learning programs apprenticeship
offers
so currently at the moment we offer
apprenticeships in the offshore wind
sector
as apprenticeship standards become
more live and more developed we will be
looking at energy support around the
domestic and the decarbonisation agenda
so kerry's already touched on a higher
education offer
but obviously one key bit that our
college really prides themselves in is
our bespoke training
so we work with employers for developing
their own courses for their own needs
there is no point just offering a static
curriculum it needs to be fluid and
forward thinking so we really pride
ourselves on that
so it's also about college it's about
looking at a talent pipeline
the college in lowest often yarmouth has
around 1800 young people currently
studying at courses
and around 5 000 adults on part-time or
full-time programs
this is the future workforce so it's
really important we engage we inspire
and we make sure that future workforce
is current and meets the skills need
so one of the ways we do that is work
with employers around industry placement
so it's really important that a student
doesn't only learn within the classroom
but also learns within the workplace
so we're always looking at opportunities
for employer projects and work
experience
so
what we've seen is we've seen a real
shift in our students
so over the last couple of years we've
got 16 year old students coming in who
are challenging
college practice challenging employers
around that sustainability and
environmental awareness we have seen a
real shift in young people's passion
and also their choice in careers
so we need to harness that and work with
them
what we can also do is we've got an
energy ambassadors program so we've got
students who are receiving extra
training who will be going out to
primary schools high schools as well as
community organizations around
exchanging knowledge and raising
aspirations
so we are still on a journey as east
coast college
as we know the energy sector and the
future need around decarbonisation
doesn't stand still so as a college we
can't afford to stand still either
so we are continuously looking around
partnerships
supporting need and driving change
towards net zero
it's really important we collaborate
and we partner but also we're actually
responsible for educating hearts and
minds
thank you everybody
[Applause]
thanks very much rachel and kerry
and last but not least university of
suffolk just down the road uh professor
nick berry and students
thomas heathwaite and daniel bundy hope
we got it right
thank you very much ian for the
introduction and welcome everyone um as
i said we've got a couple of our
students who've come to take a couple of
questions from me in a minute and it's
thomas ethwaite who's on our wildlife
ecology and conservation course also
quite um
involved in suffolk wildlife trust
and we've got daniel who is a marketing
business
degree but is now doing an intern with
justin oaks in our sustainability
institute so to very grateful for them
to come
as you said um
previously we're and we work in
conjunction with us
partner colleges and the east coast and
west
in bowie and edmonds
and we see ourselves very much as as a
community university as those two
colleges do as well
so we're here to
help as a civic university to listen to
what your needs are and to as we've said
before bespoke courses that can meet
those needs
from the energy perspective we're also
at the university looking through to
research and i don't know if peter's
here but peter goody is a phd student
with me working on energy supply within
local systems and we've got a um
a new initiative up at a dashboards park
also
partially funded by the lep called the
digitech center that uh
as part of that that's far more computer
organized but we have an eco build to
look at sustainable development
so
what i wanted to do as ian very much
said
at the start of this is that i look
around and yes i can say it because i'm
in this bracket
old stale and male
but we do have a role these old oldies
in setting this
the scene and the development going
forward the people who are going to
inherit that are
sitting next to us
the generation zed or igen or whatever
you want to call it
so we
as an older generation need to set the
baseline
that they are going to inherit and have
to take forward
so i think it's quite a apt time to ask
these guys what their
concerns are
so thomas what is your major concern for
the environment in 2021
about you know
biodiversity josh because
without biodiversity we can't sustain
our
environment and we can't sustain how we
do fence we need the biodiversity to
sustain us
if we don't have biodiversity we can't
fix the climate change crisis
which means we can't fix other crisis as
well for example
i'm doing my dissertation on how
bumblebees have either got bigger or
smoother due to
fragmentation and climate change over
150 year period
and
so
biodiversity is critical to us because
we need it for
ecosystem services such as
purifying water
we need it for purifying air
biodiversity is critical to us for our
mental health it's also critical to us
for our crops if we don't have babies if
we don't have other pollinators how can
we possibly have our food like 75 of our
food is made or pollinated either
directly or indirectly through
pollinators so it's critical that we
have biodiversity
thank you thomas slightly different to
the subject but i'll come back to that
in a minute and daniel what's your
my my main uh concern my environmental
concern is a lot about like the ocean
and
obviously waste getting inside the ocean
i i think that this actually creates
like such a big problem for wildlife and
things and that you know uh for net zero
we should get closer to you know
sustaining our oceans and things like
that
okay thank you very much
so going on i'll bring it back to
climate as its energy and that side of
things so what uh daniel i'll ask you
first this time okay what one thing
would you suggest everybody out here to
do to help against climate change the
one thing that i suggest is to
change your uh form of like
transportation if you're using a vehicle
maybe you could uh
try to get an electric vehicle or use um
another mode of transport like a bike
this will greatly reduce how much
pollution you're causing
when you're just using your car every
day
additionally to this i think that there
should be more research done into
materials and um
yeah materials that are similar to
plastic
that are biodegradable so that we can
use less plastic and hopefully cause
less waste thank you very much and and
thomas what would your advice be so
similar to daniel i
would say you should use more public
transport and also
for journeys in which you know you could
walk or you could buy
do that not don't use the car because if
we lose public transport if we do walk
if we cycle
that is
going to greatly reduce our carbon in
essence
okay thank you very much and one last
quick question quick question
are you optimistic about reaching next
zero by 2030 or 50 thomas
i am
not really that optimistic about 2030
and again to net zero unless there's a
drastic change
through cop26 so
i i struggle to see how we're going to
get to net zero by 2030 by 2050 i'm
slightly more optimistic but
i still
am hesitant to say
i'm totally optimistic that we will do
it
daniel yes um i actually have a
different view to tom um i think that
you know potentially because um
global warming and climate change is
becoming uh such a
um
it's like in the back of everyone's mind
and i think because of that people be
more encouraged to actually reduce the
pollution and climate change
i think net zero is achievable by 2030
but like like tom said
something needs to change to speed it up
thank you very much and those are just
the questions to get snapshot of where
our students are thinking and i just
want to put this in context of the
bigger student population at the moment
so
this up here is a survey that was
conducted by unite uh
students of about a thousand students
and some of the concerns that they were
having and i'll have to read it from
here because i can't see it up there um
just
i'll just
highlight a couple of sort of things um
23 of the students think that the uk's
carbon emissions targets are ambitious
enough enough
will they change their behavior well yes
88
so they will limit the number of flights
49 and 68
so they were going to go vegan i don't
know if i could do that maybe i'm the
wrong generation
76 percent say it's important to know
what brands and buy and where that comes
from looking at climate change
within the they actually say at the
bottom and this is more geared to
yesterday really within the business
side of things 76 of students say that
their feelings around climate change
will influence their career plans and
the fifth of all students would turn
down offers of higher salaries the
company's record on climate change are
poorer so beginning to see that some of
these changes going on
and a much wider survey there was
conducted by deloitte's
with
22 000 23 000 of similar people of
daniel and thomas
and actually quite interesting you see
on the the right hand side
that though climate change was the
highest concern for this generation z
there's also unemployment healthcare
education skills
and sexual harassment in this that are
coming forward as well
coming back to
some of the questions i asked here
less optimistic about the future fewer
than 50 percent see business as a force
for good in society so all our reds in
the bed go yeah
in that sixty percent fair de de
prioritizing of climate post covid
and belief wealth and income distributed
done equally
so why i sort of put that up at the end
and some of the comments that they said
is though we're talking about energy and
the some of the stuff we've heard this
morning uh fantastic what's going on in
the community about making that
transition but there's slightly there is
also a bigger picture than we're all
aware the sustainability development
goals are there for a purpose one of
them is is about around climate it
probably is
one of the biggest things but i think as
thomas said it's that biodiversity is
also
highly important and they're interlinked
you only need to read various articles
in newspapers about how climate is
changing the oceans and also the
physiology of various other organisms
within us here at the university
we do take a holistic view of this we
have
throughout our whole of our
business health
life sciences
what's the other one i can't remember
the other but we we do look at
holistically and throughout all our
modules and our courses we have
sustainability underpinning this and
applying it and if we want to go forward
new ideas times higher education this
morning saying that asking universities
to put sustainability across all of
their disciplines and to integrate
the different departments and schools
together if we are going to actually
make and train global citizenship in the
future
so
that's all i wanted to say about
higher education within the energy
sector and broader within sustainability
okay so thank you very much
[Applause]